Leanne?
Hello, Mrs. Turner.
I guess we should talk about this.
We lost Jericho
when he was… 13 weeks.
Dorothy took it hard.
This is the only thing
that brought her back.
Any questions?
No, Mr. Turner.
Whose baby is that?
Did I do something wrong?
Do you know who
you welcomed into your home?
Why haven't you told her what she did?
We have to protect ourselves.
You have to understand.
For Jericho,
there's nothing I wouldn't do.
Nothing!
I think it would be best if you were able
to make peace with Leanne.
Why are you all so afraid of her?
I don't know why I keep doing bad things.
I can feel the dark thing in me
getting bigger.
I know they're coming for me.
I'll be ready.
She grows stronger each night.
The house is filled with parasites.
Do you smell the rot?
What the hell happens now?
The end.
You can feel it now, can't you?
It's her power.
There's a war afoot.
And there's nothing that any of you
can do to stop me.